Oh, my gosh, I'm not even alive.
That's how I feel in the inside.
Sorry.
Oh, hello, everybody.
I'm sorry.
You guys have to wait so long today.
I am all over the place right now.
T-minus one day until... Okay, not even... It's like less than 24 hours.
There's less... Oh, my gosh, I forgot to... Okay.
Okay, my sound people...
Okay, so, um, my sound guy told me to do something with my audio and I forgot to do it.
So, let me do it right now.
I need to add a limiter, apparently.
Okay, give me a sec.
Oh, we're doing it live, everyone.
Woo!
We're doing it live!
Yippee!
Where is it?
Where's the mic thing?
Oh, my gosh.
Sorry, guys.
I am all over the place right now because, uh, there is a lot of stuff going on because tomorrow is my birthday concert, which is a 3D birthday concert, and there's still stuff to do for it.
So, I am all over the place.
And then after that, we have a countdown with an announcement for my birthday.
Oh, yeah.
Sorry.
In between that, I am also streaming Marvel Rivals early preview.
In between, um, in between the birthday 3D concert and, and the countdown.
So, there's that, too.
And then, um, and then July 4th is my birthday!
And then there's also another announcement there, too!
But I also have something special planned for my birthday!
Okay, so, yes, there is, and then, okay, okay, so, and, um, okay, let me fix my audio stuff real quick, and then I'll let you in on more things that's going on behind the scenes.
Um, but the reason why I'm late today was, uh, because, okay, I'm gonna add a limiter, so I don't know how messed up's gonna sound.
Um, so I'm gonna sound weird for now because I am adding a limiter.
If I sound weird, I'm adding a limiter right now.
Um, okay, so, okay.
Um, my sound guy, let me know.
I don't know if they're here, but monitor your stream if anything sounds weird.
But I have, I have inputted a, uh, a limiter now, sound team.
So let me know if it's better.
Anyway, guys, um, okay.
Okay, what is this gonna say?
Okay, so, uh, yesterday, apparently, yesterday, um, the people at Mechabreak really enjoyed my Mechabreak stream.
I don't know how many views, I actually wasn't even looking at my view count yesterday, uh, for my sponsor stream.
So I wasn't even sure, like, how well it was doing last night.
But apparently, it was doing well enough that they offered me, um, two more streams, uh, to do, uh, but I had to choose the date before July 8th.
Because I was gonna do another stream on July, I was sponsored to do another stream on July 8th as well.
But they wanted me to do two more.
And then I said, no.
But I'll do one more, because I need the money.
I, and I, like, I did enjoy Mechabreak.
I just couldn't do two, because, um, because I just, I, I had, I had too much going on.
I, but I was like, I was like, I'll take one, because I need the money.
I, guys, no, you will understand why I, I'm saying yes to all these sponsors.
You will understand after the concert, I'll reveal it all.
Because, thank you for the Akasupa, thank you, thank you.
Kat beef there for the lockdown live, the time zones.
But anyway, good luck for the concert and relax.
Even their scuff, it just makes it the money.
Thank you for the Akasupa, thank you, thank you.
But, like, um, so, they really enjoyed the, uh, Mechabreak stream that they actually asked me, um, if, uh, if I was willing to do two more, and I was like, I'll do one more.
So, I'm doing another Mechabreak stream on Sunday.
And I'll do another, I'm gonna do another, I'm gonna do one on Sunday, and then I'm gonna do another one on Tuesday.
So, uh, those would be my two Mechabreak streams that they asked me to, well, I mean, I was originally gonna be doing two, they, they asked me to do two, but they wanted to add two more, so I would have done four in total.
But I said no, because that was actually too much.
Because I also might have another sponsor on Monday as well.
I also didn't want to do, like, mecha break, mecha break, mecha break.
Like, three days of mecha break.
So I made it so that, you know, I spaced it out a little bit.
You know, one day is a little bit.
So, like, I'm all over the place right now.
I'm, like, I'm really, like, a bundle of stress at the moment.
I'm, like, a little stress ball.
Like, you squeeze me and then I just, I'm just stressed.
Like, you can't even squeeze the ball because there's just so much, like, tension in there.
That's how fucked up I am at the moment.
Anyway, um, Anton, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Surely she's raising all this money to buy a rice cooker, right, dragons?
Thank you for the super chat, Anton.
Thank you.
Oh, so, yes.
But, by the way, the reason why I was late was because my cleaner was here today.
Um, I have a monthly cleaner, uh, as suggested by you guys because it is, I don't have the time to clean my place.
Um, so she comes in here once every month.
Um, and she was a little late today.
Uh, but, uh, basically, um, okay.
So, before I go into the cleaner story, we're going to the dat- Okay, no.
This is a whole arc.
I'll go into the whole arc of this story.
It's- it's a story that goes on, um, that has its own little plot line.
So, if you guys didn't know, Dad was at, uh, the dog sitter.
And, uh, because, uh, Daddy needs her me time.
So.
And, like, I really wanted to sleep in.
And I really, really needed, like, time for myself.
And I needed to sleep in.
So, I put him at the dog sitter for two days.
Also, Waffle Maker!
Welcome to Tomato Farm!
Welcome, welcome!
Anyway, so, like, so the story goes, he was at the dog sitter.
So, you know how yesterday, um, I couldn't tell the story yesterday because it was a sponsor, and I couldn't, like, you know, have to focus on the game itself because I got paid to.
Um, so I can't really, like, diverge into, you know, you can tell I was trying to avoid saying, like, Transformers, like, you know, when we were Falcon, I'd be like, Transformers, Roland, oh my god, we're basically Starscream and, like, his gang.
When we were doing a 3v3, I wanted to be, like, Decepticons, go, and be like, let's go, we're basically Starscream's gang right now.
I really wanted to, oh my god, I wanted to say all that, but I couldn't because, obviously, I had to, um, I had to, like, you know, avoid copyright stuff.
We were, like, the Seekers and everything, uh, but I couldn't say that, so I had to avoid all, like, the copyright stuff while, while I was trying to talk about Mechabrick.
Um, I'm surprised I got away with Chigs, Chicks, Dig, Giant, Robo.
I think they just didn't know where that song came from.
Because, like, in the, in the briefing, we were supposed to avoid copyright stuff and, like, you know, trying to sing copyright music, but I think they didn't know where that song came from, so I got away with seeing that, like,
anyway, um, anyway, so, uh, basically, on Canada Day, um, if you guys weren't there for yesterday's Elden Ring stream, I was saying how, like, oh, um, I didn't, I don't know if I should do anything on Canada Day, because, like, you know, uh, it's always super crowded and,
like, I'm just there to buy overpriced food and, like, it's so hot and, like, I'm just gonna be in a line for a while just to get my overpriced food and there's not really much to do there other than listening to, like, live music and, like, just community stuff and things for kids.
And then I still, and then, guess who went out and bought overpriced?
And guess what happened?
I was like, you know, you know what?
Okay, it's so fucked up.
It was so fucked up.
I regretted it.
I was like, I'm not gonna do it because I know what's gonna happen.
I even knew I was, I, like, I can't predict it was gonna happen until I grabbed, like, the step-by-step of what's gonna happen if I ever, if I go out to Canada, for Canada Day, on, like, those Canada Day festivities.
And, like, past Doki warned future Doki that that was gonna happen and I still did it anyway.
So, basically, I was like, okay, I still have a couple of hours before the, uh, uh, the, the sponsor.
So, you know what?
Let me just, yeah, there's, like, a special event going on for Canada Day near me.
So, let me just take an Uber there and just, you know, see how we're, what, like, oh, there seems to be some good-ass food trucks there.
Let me go check it out.
So, I, you know, took an Uber to, like, this place where they were running some Canada Day, like, events and stuff.
And then there was, like, live music and stuff like that.
And then there were food trucks.
So, my goal was to just really go to the food trucks because I also thought there would be, like, stuff people would sell, like, like, a little miniature, uh, how did you fall for the tourist trap?
Liam, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's not even a tourist trap.
It's a Canadian trap.
Like, it's a Canadian trap.
I, oh, I could have just celebrated at home.
I don't even care that much.
I could just Uber Eats.
But anyway, uh, anyway, so, um, Um, so, I was, like, I was, like, okay, I'm gonna go there and, like, you know, just, you know, check it out And just see, just, you know, maybe there will be some good food trucks.
Maybe there'll be stuff to buy.
So, I got there and then, like, literally, there's no, it's just, like, if things for children and, like, families to do And like, it's like, oh man, join this community club for like, I don't fucking know, for like some dance or whatever.
Like this is like some community clubs to join and stuff like that.
Like, oh, want to visit this ancient, like vintage bus museum?
And then there's like, you know, oh, look at this like university.
University advertisement booth where like, spin this wheel to get a free item.
And then like, you know, I walked out and I was like, oh, there's the food trucks.
And then, oh my God, there was, I was like, oh, the line is not too bad.
Like, oh, that, like I have, hmm, I have two and a half, I have, let's see, two hours before I have to get home and, you know, get prepared for my sponsor.
And then, and then, so I was just like, all right, let me just line up for this, line up at this food truck.
This seems like a really good food truck too, after looking through all the trucks that were there.
And then, I stood in that line and then I waited and I waited and I waited and I waited and I waited for an entire hour.
And then, I was just like, this morning, I was like, guys, I waited for an hour for a while and I went, I waited for an hour and the queue was coming, but anyway, it hanged for me.
So, I was like, dude, and got like, boys and I was like, boys and I literally sat down for that chauffeur.
And then, at that time, boy So I also bought chicken nuggies, too, because I was like, I waited a fucking hour for this food truck.
And I was like, I'm gonna fucking, I'm gonna spend money.
I'm fucking, if I'm gonna eat, I'm gonna eat.
If I waited an hour, I'm not buying one item.
I'm not, I'm not buying one item if I waited an entire fucking hour.
So, it didn't even look that long.
I was like, oh, this line doesn't look too bad.
And then, I also bought some shitty popcorn, too.
That's what made me so sad.
Anyway, by the time, by the time I bought, I got the food, and I got the food, by the time I got the food, and, um, and everything, it was already 8 p.m.
And I was walking, because, okay, and then, the place I was at, they closed down the road.
So, I had to, like, walk back to the road with the cars to get an Uber back home.
And by the time I got home, it was, like, 8.30.
And, like, my, my sponsor's stream was at 9 p.m.
And so, I literally went to this Canada Day event, went to the food trucks, lined up, bought my food, and then I went home.
Happy Canada Day to me.
Um, sorry, let me, correction, bought my overpriced fucking food.
That could have got for cheaper on Uber Eats.
And, and then I went home.
Happy Canada Day.
So, um, anyway.
So, yeah, you know, past Doki predicted that this was gonna happen, and then future Doki was like, no, it'll be different.
Like, she was like, oh, man, you know what?
I should, like, go outside and, like, you know, enjoy, um, the festivities.
Anyway, so, yes, so that's part one of the story.
Part two of the story is that... Jay, welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Part two of the story is basically, um, since dad was at the dog sitter, he actually came back late last night.
Um, but just before my sponsor stream, he came back.
And the thing is, okay, so it's his usual dog sitter that he really likes.
So I was like, oh, hey, yeah, um, was he, like, was it fine?
And she was like, yeah, she was, like, did he, I was like, did he poop and pee?
And she was like, yeah, he, uh, yeah, he did.
He pooped and pee at 8 p.m.
And I was like, okay, so I don't have to walk him after that.
So, um, the thing is, so, there's a little setup to this, to the story.
Let me set the story up for you guys.
Before he was at the dog sitter, um, I had one can of his food left.
And this is, like, a specially prescribed canned food.
And I had one left for one day.
But he was at there for two days.
So, I asked the dog sitter if she could buy, uh, a new set of, a new set of wet food, uh, for him.
And you could get it at any veterinarian.
She went to two veterinarians.
And they didn't have the usual canned food that he gets.
Like, the flavor.
It's the same brand.
But he didn't, they didn't have his flavor.
Which was beef and vegetables.
So, um, they only had beef.
So, the thing is, like, my dog sitter already went to two vets.
And this was the first time where, like, they didn't have, um, the usual.
Well, so, uh, so, uh, he only had beef.
So, I was like, okay, that's fine.
Um, that's fine.
It's just for, like, an extra day.
You know, it's just for, like, one day.
That should be fine.
Um, so, the thing about the...
Okay, so, before I explain to you what was wrong with the beef wet food can, let me just say, the day, the...
Today.
Me, thank you for the 10 gifted chips.
Thank you, thank you.
Today.
So, he did the usual thing.
He woke me up in the morning for food.
And I was like, and I opened the can of beef.
Because his, uh, usual beef and vegetables is coming tomorrow.
Um, because it takes a couple...
I ordered it off of Amazon.
Um, just because, like, I didn't want to, you know, I didn't want to book an Uber trip to the vet that's, like, his usual vet that's, like, you know, like, 15 minutes away.
So, I figured I'd just Amazon order it because it's just more convenient.
Because it's just, you know, I just thought it was more convenient to just Amazon it.
Um, and so, um, I opened his can of beef, wet food.
And then I opened it.
I was like, whoa, this is, like, super chunky and, like, filling.
And, like, I usually give him half a can for his, uh, usual, like, beef and vegetables.
Uh, for this one, I gave him one-third because it was a lot.
It was, like, so much.
I was like, holy shit.
Like, this is a lot for, um, for, like, for his meal.
So, he got one-third versus half a can.
And then I went back to sleep because I was like, you know, he wakes me at a fucking six in the morning.
Um, he wakes me up at six in the morning to eat.
And then usually, how his routine is like, is that after, after I, you know, um, feed him in the morning, he lets me sleep for at least three to four hours.
So, he lets me sleep in for three to four more hours before he needs to do walkie time.
So.
So, he woke me up again.
He woke me up at nine.
But I was like, no, this is too much.
I need to go back to sleep.
And then he woke me up again at ten.
And then I was like, okay, that's fine.
Like, that's okay.
But then I was like, oh, I'm, like, so overworked and everything.
I really, really needed a shower before I take him for his walks.
So, I took a shower because he has let me do that before.
Like, you know, he could wait, usually.
And then I got out of the shower.
And then I was like, what's that smell?
I was like, oh, no.
Oh, no.
And so, I was like, where did you do it, Dad?
And then I went to the front door, the front of my door.
And he pooped three times at the front of my door.
And they weren't his usual little doggy poops.
They were, like, really big boy poops.
And I was like, what?
I was like, that came out of you?
I was like, they were, it was not even, like, his usual poop size, too.
Two of them were absolutely big boy poops.
And I was like, are you okay?
I was like, I was like, oh, what?
And then, two of them were on this, okay, I, okay, and then, the thing is, oh, my gosh.
I have a really cute little carpet that's shaped like a bear.
And he, two of the poops were on the cute little bear carpet that I have, that I used as, like, a rug, that, sorry, the little cute bear rug that I bought to be, you know, used to, like, wipe my shoes and everything.
And he, he, like, pooped two of the poops on the little cute bear.
But then the third poop didn't fit on the cute bear carpet, so he pooped on, he pooped beside it because they were too big.
It didn't fit.
Carl, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
And then, and then I was like, oh, my God.
So I was like, well, guys, you still need your walkies.
So I, like, picked up the poop, and I, like, took the poop with me to the dog park, and then I took him to the dog park, and then I noticed, I was like, wait, did you pee, too?
Because I freaked out, I was like, wait, if he pooped, what if he also peed?
So then I, like, monitored him when he, like, got to the dog park, and then I noticed, that's not a lot of pee.
That's not a lot.
But then, he also pooped two more times.
Two more times at the dog park.
I was like, but they were, like, his usual poop size.
They were the usual size, by the way.
Not the ginormous big boy ones.
It was his usual size.
But he still did it two more times.
I was like, oh, my, I'm, okay.
Anyway, so, there was thought there would be a rug cleaning fun, so, here, Shady, thank you in the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Anyway, so then, I went home, and I was like, and I looked down, and my cute little, bear rug, and I noticed the stain.
Not only, I think he peed on it, and then he started, because I'm
on top of it, so, it's okay, guys.
I got it on, I got it at Daiso.
At least it was cheap, but it was very cute.
It was very awesome.
I was like, is this salvageable?
And I was like, this isn't.
I was like, I'm not cleaning this.
I'm throwing this away.
It's not salvageable.
It's not.
I threw it away, guys.
There's no rug cleaning fund.
It's just, it's gone.
It's in the goddamn, it's in the fucking trash downstairs.
Ready to be collected.
But yes, and then I was like, I was like, oh my god, I'm sorry.
And then I texted the dog sitter.
I was just like, okay, so, he had an accident, this morning, and he's never had an accident before.
He was, he's never done this before.
So I was like, I was like, I was like, what happened?
And then the dog sitter was like, oh, I think I might have overfed him last night with his new dog food.
I was like, he's like, yeah, I gave him half the can of, I gave him half, half the can, because I told, like, because she knows, usually, usually, it's half for his other canned food, but the beef and veggies is like, a lot less filling.
I guess, it's a lot less filling.
So she gave half a can of just pure beef.
And,
so, I was just like, oh my god, I got so scared that he's gonna have another act, I got so scared, I like, walked him before, I walked him at like, at like, five, because I knew the cleaner was still here, because, but okay, the cleaner was still here,
so then I was like, okay, I need to walk you, I'm gonna walk you three times a day, because I'm scared.
I'm like, but anyway, I was like, I wasn't crying about it, but obviously I was like, in distress about it to my manager, because I, you know, I went through like, a lot of grief in the morning, having to deal with that, because I've never, he's never had an accident before,
ever since he got like, you know, potty trained, he's never had an accident before, so I was like, and like, he's never, you know, he would let, I knew his schedule, and he knew, he knows my schedule, and like, so I was like, freaking out, because I was just like,
I was like, why did this happen?
I was like, I'm so sad, this happened.
Like, he's never had an accident before.
Oh, and then, you know, obviously, I think I was also like, super over, like, I'm like, really stressed out and overworked at the moment, because of like, the birthday week and everything.
And so like, obviously, I felt really bad, because I was like, I'm sorry, dad, if I wasn't so tired in the morning, and felt like I felt so dirty, I would have just walked you, instead of taking a shower first.
I'm sorry.
And like, the worst part is that he barks at everything.
So like, I didn't realize it were emergency, I have to go barks, because he always barks at the smallest fucking thing.
So like, if every time, like, everything is an emergency to him.
So when will I know when it's an actual emergency?
Like, the dad that cried, whoop, like, everything is an emergency to him.
So like, how did I know this was like, a real, real emergency, where he has to go?
Because he's done this to me so many times in the morning.
Where, but he used to let me shower, in the past.
It's all an emergency.
Caleb, thank you.
Welcome to Tomato Fire.
Welcome, welcome.
Unlucky.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That didn't just do his business.
That was chemical warfare of all kinds.
The poor bear and the house.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
So, anyway, so that was, that was the dad story.
Now, part three.
But that was, part three is shorter.
And that was why, the cleaner, took a lot longer than usual, to clean the place.
Because I had her clean the area.
The,
the area where he decided to go to do an emergency stop at.
That's why, that's why it went on.
Um, the, the hazard zone.
That's why the cleaner took a lot longer, um, to finish up.
Because I had her, like, extra clean in that area.
But yeah, that, that is the whole story.
I, I had so many things I wanted to talk about.
But like, this took up, this one story, took up 30 minutes of the stream.
So, yeah.
Um, uh, Carl, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
When I gotta go, I gotta go.
And I mean it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
so, yes.
So, yes.
That, I mean, that could be a data.
I mean, that's basically a data update.
Right now, he's just, he's just sleeping next to me at the moment.
As if he didn't like, you know, fuck up my entire morning.
Oh, I guess.
But yes, he is, um, he is basically sleeping beside me.
Anyway, we're not finishing Halo today.
Um, just because I am very busy.
Very, very busy.
Um, there's a lot of stuff I have to do for tomorrow's concert.
And also the birthday stream on the 4th.
And also the announce, the, the countdown slash announcement, uh, tomorrow.
After the concert.
So, in the end, a lot of stuff came up.
Like, a lot of like, I guess like technical difficulties.
Or, and like things I need to like, solve and stuff.
So, um, um, I have to like, uh, work on that after the stream.
So I can't do a super long endurance stream.
And I also have like, a teensy little bit of a headache.
Uh, I didn't, I'm gonna, I'm gonna take like, uh, botana real quick.
Uh, for my tiny headache.
It's not that bad.
It's just teeny tiny.
Like I could, it's like, it's not even, I wouldn't say a headache.
It's like, a pressure, you know?
Like, you know, it's like, not really a headache, but just like a slight pressure.
Um, on the sat, like on the eyebrows type deal.
Uh, but like, yeah, that's why, uh, I totally, uh, that's why I can't do a super long stream today.
Most likely we'll just try and finish one level, which is the library.
apparently the fucking worst level in this game.
It's the, it's the worst level of this game.
So like, I'm ready.
I'm ready to play it.
Um, but yes, um, I hope you enjoyed my, my life update.
It was, it was, oh, it was definitely a wild ride for me the whole day.
Um, let's see.
Oh my gosh.
Also, I'll give you guys a little thing I want to talk to you guys about.
I'll give you guys another little, uh, life update that I wanted to talk to you guys about.
Like, I think like yesterday, but I forgot to, but, um, okay, so we got a scam email.
Like, uh, my manager sent me this like scam email, uh, because they're like, oh, hey, like, what is this?
And it's based, I'll read you the email out.
And like, at first I like freaked out.
Cause I was like, what the fuck?
I didn't realize it was a scam at first.
Cause I thought it was legit.
Cause I'd never seen this before.
So, um, let me see.
Where is this?
Oh, wait, did I, did they, uh, oh, here you go.
Let me tell you.
Dear creator, I've become aware that your recent content features my music, which has been used without proper authorization.
Well, I hope this is an oversight.
It nonetheless represents a direct infringement of my exclusive copyright to this work.
I'm genuinely interested in resolving this situation amicably, uh, as soon as possible.
However, I must inform you that shouldn't, an amicable resolution not be reached.
I've already taken steps by contacting Astra and their legal department for further, further actions.
In such a scenario, you need to interact directly with their legal team, as well as paste, as well as face potential sanctions for copyright infringement that could be applied to your YouTube channel.
I trust you're aware of the consequences.
Accumulating three copyright strikes will lead to indefinite channel suspension.
My aim is to avoid such an outcome.
So, like, I was like, when?
I always try to Google royalty-free music.
So, I was like, what the fuck?
like, and then I was like, when did this happen?
What the fuck did I have?
Unless it was karaoke, but like, even then, like, I use Carafun for my karaoke and that's, like, legal.
Like, like, I pay, like, a monthly subscription to that to make sure that, like, I can sing these songs during karaoke.
So, I was like, so confused.
And then, I Googled the email.
Like, okay, and the email was from a Japanese, like, email, like, domain thing.
And I was like, oh shit, but Japanese people take, like, copyright very seriously.
So I was like, oh shit, maybe it's legit.
Because it was like, dot JP, like, the email address.
So I was like, oh my gosh, maybe, like, it is serious.
Like, but when the fuck did I use music?
Like, um, like, illegally.
And then, and then, so, uh, so then I, I, like, Googled the, the, like, everything he wrote.
And then it was literally a, it was a scam.
Like,
it was, it was, I'll link it.
I found a Reddit one.
And, like, they literally just, they basically, um, it's like the same, almost the same email, but they just change whatever the, like, music company is.
And everyone's like, oh yeah, I got the same email too.
And yeah, so I'll, I'll show you guys, like, this basically, the Reddit thread I saw.
And it was literally the same, like, the same, like, the same, similar subject and similar, like, um, um, paragraphs and stuff.
Except they changed, like, one to two words.
So I was like, oh, okay, thank God.
All right.
I knew I didn't break any laws.
But I doubted myself because the email came from a Japanese email.
So I doubted myself because I was like, oh, shit, no.
They, they take that shit very seriously.
So, but it was a fake Japanese email.
And, so I was like, God damn it.
I almost fell for it just because it came from a .JP email.
Like, if it, if it didn't come from a .JP, I would have not taken this seriously.
Like, right off the bat, I'd be like, that's a scam.
Like, but I second, I, like, second doubted myself.
I've actually doubted myself.
I was like, oh my God, when did I do this?
I was like, I was just like, I was like, when did I do that?
I don't remember me.
I must have, though, because the email is .JP.
So, so, so, like, it, like, I, they almost got me.
They all, they, they almost got me, guys.
Um, yeah, I, like, doubted myself there.
Anyway, I'm sorry.
This was a very long tangent.
Like, I went through a lot today.
Uh, but let's play it.
Let's play Halo!
Halo!
I'm sorry to everybody that's been waiting for this game.
Waiting for me to end my long-ass Satsunan portion.
Yeah.
Now it's actual Halo time.
Don't worry.
Now you can tap back in.
We're actually playing Halo now.
Also, let me get more water.
I'll be right back.
It's loading, by the way.
Alright.
It's loading.
I'm just getting more water.
Uh, Admiral, thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
You say you're ready for the library?
You ain't.
Look on the bright side, though, Doki.
You're not playing this on Legendary.
Good luck.
You got this.
But make sure use of everything on that level.
You need to.
Oh, my God.
I'm, I'm a little worried.
Alright.
Our mission today is that...
Oh, sorry.
Like, it's just so iconic.
Oh.
Alright.
Uh, Clorox, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
God, I don't know how ready I am.
I...
Most likely, I'm not ready, to be fair.
Mentally, I'm not there.
I know mentally I'm not there right now.
Alright.
Wait, where am I?
Oh, shit.
Okay, I was gonna say...
Wait, is this...
Okay, wait.
Which one is...
Okay, yeah, this is the...
Wait.
Which one is the...
Low quality...
Wait, you can't tell which one is the low quality graphics.
I actually can't tell.
I...
Oh, shit.
Screen is back.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, that's good.
That's fine.
I forgot to...
Okay, guys.
I need help.
I can't tell which one is low quality.
I...
I can't tell which one is the remaster.
This is the...
Is this...
Follow me.
Okay, no.
This isn't.
This is the low quality.
Okay, never mind.
This is the original OG graphics.
Okay, I figured it out.
I was struggling a little bit.
Oh, my God.
Where is he?
I have to follow him!
Oh, my God.
Okay.
I need to follow him.
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
Quick, write a message.
Oh, wait.
I didn't give him the super chat ticket.
I have to parkour?
Oh, my God.
Okay, let's figure this out.
Get out of here!
Oh, there's a door.
Oh, my God.
There's a door.
Oh.
Wait.
Okay.
Okay, I can do this.
Okay, now I know.
Now I know.
I know now.
I hate this already.
Holy fuck!
I don't even know where he went!
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Will I have enough?
How do I find a shotgun?
Will I even have enough fucking ammo?
Oh, my God.
Word of...
What is he doing?
Where is he?
Where's my buddy?
I'm following as much as I can follow.
Oh, my God.
I
didn't do this again!
Oh, my God.
What was my checkpoint?
I don't even know!
Oh!
Oh, no!
No!
Checkpoint!
Oh!
Oh,
my God.
I'm already low HP.
Oh my god, I'm dead.
I'm dead.
I'll take my own life.
I go out on my own terms.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I can't see on this level.
I understand now.
Guys, I understand.
Okay.
I understand now.
Oh my god.
How am I already getting hit?
How?
Oh my god, how do I win this level?
How do I win?
How do I get out of
here?
Oh my god, there he is.
Oh!
Oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
We must get up there.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No!
Oh, the door's here!
I hate this.
I hate this level.
I hate this level!
Oh my god.
Oh, fuck!
I don't have ammo!
There's
no...
Please, please!
Oh my god.
Guys, there's no time to pick weapons.
Pick up weapons, guys.
It's like hell.
How do you pick up weapons when you're in hell?
They don't give you time!
Follow me.
They don't give you any time!
I am a genius.
How much to turn it out to...
Guys, I'm not even staying alive in normal!
And you...
Guys, I can't even stay alive in hard mode.
I...
Why...
Why do you think I'd be any better in Legendary?
Oh my god.
Oh!
My god!
Oh my god!
I'm so...
This is hard.
It must be an easier way.
There...
There must be...
There must be an easier way.
Okay.
Go slow.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
I got stuck!
I already fucked up.
I...
Okay, we'll go slower.
We'll go slower.
Maybe slow is the way.
Or...
We'll go slower.
Slow is the way.
Oh my god!
And then he spawns next to me!
No.
No, I'm not.
Sir.
Sir, I'm going through a lot right now.
I'm going through a lot.
Okay.
Okay, it's five.
Oh my god, it's five.
It's so five.
We'll go slow.
Okay.
Alright, we're going slow.
We're going slow.
Slow and steady.
Can I steal your gun?
Whoa!
Oh my god!
Okay, I'm ready.
I'm ready.
Guys, there's so much.
There's so much.
Okay, I'm ready now.
We go slow.
Okay.
Slow and steady.
Get rid of the bombs.
Okay.
Alright.
We got rid of the bomb one.
It's five.
We're five.
We're so healthy.
Let's see.
And then, the bomb two.
Where's the bomb two?
Oh, I knew you were real.
Okay, the bomb two down.
Okay.
Bomb two down.
Oh my god, that's a shotgun.
Oh my god.
Alright.
Oh!
Okay, we got shotgun.
Alright.
We got one of the bombs.
We are near the index chamber.
Follow me.
Oh my god, there he is.
I fucking knew you existed.
Oh my god.
I heard you.
Oh!
Okay, it's five.
It's five.
We're so healthy.
Okay, we're so healthy.
Okay, we just gotta get rid of these guys.
Alright.
We're so healthy now.
Okay, we have... Oh, nice.
We have ammo.
Oh!
Oh my god!
The energy field of bombs can't use the index.
We must get...
Are you fucking... No!
Oh my god, checkpoint!
Oh my god!
There's hope.
There...
Ah!
Ah There is hope in this world.
There is hope in this world.
Oh my god.
I can't feel hope, guys.
It's possible!
Wait, what's that over there?
What is that?
Oh god, I really want to go through it.
I really, I really want to go through that hole.
It's so tempting.
Oh my god, that's a shotgun though.
I need that.
Okay.
Oh.
It's okay.
It's not okay.
Jesus Christ, there's so many.
There's so many.
Okay, we gotta grab this before they come back.
Come on.
Is there any extra guns?
No!
Is there any extra?
Any extra?
Any?
No extra bullets!
Oh no.
There's no extra bullets.
Please!
It's okay.
We're fine.
We're so fine.
As long as the bombs don't get me.
Ah!
I can't see the guns!
You don't understand!
It's so hard to see the guns!
It's so dark!
You don't understand!
I can't appear!
It's so dark!
I can't see anything!
The flashlight does nothing!
It actually does nothing!
Oh my god!
I can barely see anything!
Even with the flashlights!
Oh my god!
Oh god!
Not the bombs!
Get them out of here!
Okay.
Okay, it's fine.
Oh my god!
Of course it was next to me!
Oh, I hear you!
I hear you!
Come on, there has to be one more!
No!
You gotta be kidding me!
Come on!
No!
Wait!
Come on!
Oh fucking yes!
I'll use this.
I'll use- Oh!
What's shutting me?
This is fine.
This is so fine.
We just gotta get rid of them.
We just gotta get rid of them!
Oh, this is not fine.
Oh my god.
Oh god, there's still so many.
There's still so many.
Please!
Did you open it?
Oh, he opened it.
He opened it.
I couldn't tell.
I can't tell!
Okay, we're okay.
We're okay.
Why are you laughing at my pain?
Fuck you fucker!
You fucker!
Oh my god, this is so one bullet.
Oh my god.
Nine more doors.
One of you must have a shotgun!
Please!
Where is he?
Where did he go?
How am I supposed to know where to go?
The flood must not escape the instruments.
Where did he go?
AHHHHH!
You fucker!
Oh my god!
He's right behind me, isn't he?
Oh my god, he's right behind me.
I knew it.
I see you.
I fucking see you.
I fucking see you over there.
Oh my god.
And no glass breaks.
Break a fucking struggle.
Holy shit!
A fucking course!
Can't get me, I have high ground.
Oh shit!
Maybe you can!
Oh my god!
Oh!
If only I have a shotgun!
If only they carry shotguns!
What happened to my shotgun floods?
What happened?
Oh my god, that's...
No, that's a pistol.
God damn it, that's a pistol!
AHHHHH!
NOOOOO!
I don't have ammo!
Please don't do this to me!
Oh, please don't do this.
Please don't do this.
Please!
No!
No, not you!
Not you!
Anything but you!
Oh my god!
Nothing, please!
My suffering doesn't give you that much pleasure!
Guys, I would...
If I had a choice, I wouldn't be meleeing.
Guys!
Guys, I don't have a choice.
I...
Oh no!
You must continue!
This game's relation to research facilities are most impressive!
Perhaps what I'm telling you is...
Oh no!
I'm running out!
I'm running out of hope!
I'm running out of so much hope!
Please!
No!
Yes!
It does!
Nice!
Thank you!
Where am I?
Oh my god!
It's here!
It's my worst nightmare!
Oh my god!
Where am...
I'm supposed to go straight!
Oh my god!
I have ammo!
I actually have ammo!
Why do I have to reload?
Okay.
Okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
Okay.
It's not okay, but it's okay.
It's fine.
Like, fuck that one guy in particular.
Oh, fuck me in particular, I guess.
I guess.
Alright, that's fine.
That's fine.
Okay.
I'm okay.
I walked past multiple shotguns.
The prop doesn't show up on my feed.
So I can't tell.
We must continue.
This way, please.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I'm just standing here.
Because I feel the most safe.
I feel the most safe when I'm back there.
When I'm on high ground.
Oh my god.
No!
Oh!
Yes!
Plan.
Definitely plan.
Oh my god.
I'm crying.
I'm dying and he's just humming.
Oh my god.
There is a god.
There is...
This installation's research facilities are most impressive.
Perhaps you will have time to see them later.
I'm crying and he's just laughing.
He's just laughing.
Oh my...
Of course.
Of course they're behind me.
They're behind me, aren't they?
A fucking corsair behind me, aren't they?
Oh my god.
Oh, I have overshield.
Thank god.
I actually found overshield.
Thank fucking god.
Okay.
I have to reload.
Alright, I'm moving up.
I'm moving up.
Oh my god.
Checkpoint.
There's an actual checkpoint.
Oh my god.
I actually found a checkpoint, guys.
Okay.
I just want to make sure they pop first.
I need to make sure they pop before I go anywhere.
I got popped them like pimples.
I don't trust them.
Where is he?
Oh, where is he?
I don't know.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
Oh, thank you so much.
Oh my god.
I actually have help.
Thank you.
Oh, where am I?
Where am I?
Wait.
Why are they coming with me?
Please.
Come with me.
Come with me to this journey.
Episode 3.
Drama loop.
Choco.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Why can't they be with me?
I don't understand.
Holy shit.
Why do they take so long?
Okay.
That was bullshit.
These guys took so long.
Flood activity has caused a failure in a drone control subsystem.
I must reset the backup unit.
Please continue on.
Oh.
Oh, I thought I'd die.
I was...
I was gonna accept my fate.
I was gonna be like, okay, I'm dead.
I actually...
Oh my god, they're with me!
Oh my god, they're here!
Guys, the flashlight is gonna do nothing for me.
It actually does not help me at all.
Oh my god, they're actually here.
Oh my god, I actually have help.
That's crazy.
I thought I heard...
I thought they were...
No, don't you touch them!
Don't you touch them!
Oh my god.
Okay, but like, I'm a little scared now.
No!
No way!
Are you serious?
Are you fucking...
Okay, okay.
Okay.
I didn't realize they would do all that damage.
Oh my god.
At least my sentence are here.
Thank god.
Blood activity has caused a failure in a drone control subsystem.
I must reset the backup unit.
Please continue on.
Okay.
I will rejoin you when I've completed my task.
Okay, it's fine.
We have the poppers.
Holy shit.
They do so much damage though.
I thought...
I thought like...
I was doing okay.
But hold your position until...
Guess that's not happening.
Whoops.
That's...
That's an accident.
Oh my god.
Okay, I got full focus this.
I actually have to full focus this, guys.
Oh my god.
Please.
Okay.
We still have lots of ammo left.
Please.
I don't want to do this again.
Okay.
We got one of the nades up.
Oh no.
Don't you dare.
Don't you dare hit him.
Get him away.
Oh my god.
How is there so much more?
How do you...
How do you still exist?
We did it.
We made it.
Okay.
Somehow.
We actually made it.
Okay.
We're gonna...
We're gonna see if there's...
Oh, there's no extra guns.
No!
I'm sorry.
I didn't know you were still fighting.
I...
I didn't know.
I couldn't save you.
I'm sorry.
If I knew you were still fighting.
Oh, and then there was one.
And then there was one.
I didn't know you were still fighting, guys.
I thought it was over.
I was trying to find more guns!
The sentinels can use their weapons to manage the flood only for a short time.
Speed is of the essence.
That's a fucking lie.
Okay, that's a lie!
I found out we had to go slow!
You're liars!
Speed was not the essence!
I tried with speed and it lied to me!
What kill?
What?
Is that a rocket launcher?
That's a rocket launcher.
That's a... That's a goddamn rocket launcher.
That's a...
That's a fucking rocket launcher.
They have rocket launchers now?!
Oh my god!
What do you mean?
I only have one rocket launcher!
Where are they going?
Oh my god!
They're just babies.
I hear so many things behind that door!
I hear them all behind that door!
Okay.
It's just the babies for now.
It's just the babies.
Okay.
I'm not...
You're not getting my rocket launchers.
Okay.
Honestly, I'm gonna take the shotgun.
I...
Honestly, I can't...
I'm not risking it.
I can't...
I can't afford using...
I actually can't afford using anything but the shotgun right now.
Wait, what's over here?
I see you.
Am I supposed to go down here?
I...
I can't tell.
I can't tell!
There's so many paths!
Which way is the right path?
Okay, thank god I'm doing one level.
I think, like, if I did a chance of this, I would have been broken by...
Just by the end of this level.
I would not have been a person.
Alright.
Yeah.
Bye.
Nice, we're okay.
Get out of here!
I know, I knew it.
I knew you were on top.
I heard you scoing...
Oh my god, I'm turning into XPC.
I'm...
I'm chatteling my inner XPC right now.
I am.
Is there anything here?
What the fuck?
Why did they told me to go into this corner?
Oh, Sage, thank you for super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Where is it for Doki to do the last of Halo after she's done the game?
What the...
I don't know.
I don't know if I'm strong enough, guys.
Okay.
We'll make sure these guys die.
What's hitting...
Oh, I knew it!
I knew you were behind me!
I knew it was...
She's right behind me, isn't he?
I knew it.
I fucking knew it.
Oh, hey, nice.
Okay.
What?
What are you doing here?
Get out of here!
Give me your shotgun, too.
Wait.
Oh, shit!
Oh!
What?
Oh, no.
I'm one.
He's just gonna hit me and then I'm gonna be dead.
I need...
I need shields.
How is there still...
People trying to kill me!
Okay.
1 HP and a Dream right now.
Oh.
This is not the best time.
This is absolutely not the best time.
Okay.
Just keep going forward.
Just keep swimming.
Just keep sw... Oh my
god, there he is.
Oh my god, there I am!
Okay.
Just keep swimming.
Oh, there's no help back here.
The installation was...
I just want one help back!
Just one!
One!
Please!
No, no.
I refuse to die by the little guys.
I refuse to die by these little guys.
Okay.
That's fine.
He's just laughing at me.
He's just laughing at me and my suffering.
Is this how people feel?
Oh, I only have four bullets left!
Hey, yes!
I have to use this instead.
I only have four.
Oh, I don't have grenades.
Oh!
Elevator!
Take me to safety elevator!
Go up!
They can't get me when I'm up!
Okay.
We're good.
But I don't wanna ride the elevator!
Me too!
I don't... Mom!
Dad!
Pick me up!
Can someone pick me up, please?
I wanna go home!
Oh!
Sentinous!
I would conjecture that the other species currently on the installation is responsible for releasing the flog.
They seem most persistent in their attempts to access restricted areas.
That's a rocket launcher.
I can see it.
I see it.
Okay.
I see a health pack!
I also see a health pack!
Can I go this way?
Okay.
Checkpoint done!
I need a final shotgun though!
Hey, guys!
Wait, I can't...
Okay.
I thought it... I thought it'd go further.
I... I thought...
I thought it'd go further, guys!
I really did!
I...
It looked like it'd go further!
I even crouched and aimed at the ceiling!
It...
Wait, I like vaguely remember this level now.
I remember.
Cause like...
10 years ago...
One of my friends...
Was like, you gotta try Halo.
And then they took me to this level.
I've repressed this memory.
I...
I've repressed this...
I re... I remember now.
I remember now.
They started me at this level.
I actually remember.
I've actually...
I don't...
I remember this corridor.
I...
I was like, wait a minute.
I feel like...
I feel like a sense of deja vu.
And I was like, wait, no.
Now I remember why I'm feeling deja vu right now.
I...
I don't remember much from this level.
But like...
Bits and pieces of it...
Is like...
Bringing familiarity to me.
And now I know why.
Now I know why.
I've crossed these halls before.
Where am I supposed to go now?
I'm like, a little lost.
Oh, here.
He's unlocking the door.
Okay.
I was so confused.
Because they don't look like doors.
Sometimes they just don't look like doors.
Guys.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Nice.
Okay, I just have to blow them up just in case.
What in the...
Protagonist unlocked.
Trauma memory.
I've played these games before.
It's...
I'm actually going through trauma right now.
I'm...
Oh my god.
What?
Oh, did I kill myself?
I killed myself.
I killed...
I go through all the way here.
Oh.
It's this way.
Okay.
We gotta get rid of the...
The nades.
Okay.
Oh.
Okay, I wanna make sure I grab as much ammo as possible.
Alright.
This way.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it brought me all the way back here.
No, I can't.
I can't.
This level sucks.
I can.
I...
100% yes.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
If I trap myself in this corner, I'll live.
That's how it goes.
I'll live in this corner.
Okay.
We're fine.
Jesus Christ.
These things are so tanky too.
That's the worst part.
Oh my god.
Thank god.
Here you go.
I'm not actually fine though.
Oh, I don't have...
Oh, I don't have any more shotguns though!
Are you serious?
Explode!
Oh my god.
I almost walked into it.
Okay.
We're not fine though.
Oh!
Why don't they just explode?
Please.
All I want you to do is explode.
That's all I want.
Oh.
I just need a shotgun.
Any shotguns anywhere?
Anywhere?
Where are all the shotguns?
Please!
Oh my god.
He has the high ground too.
That's okay.
I can do a loop-de-loop.
I'll just do a loop-de-loop.
Please!
One of you must be...
Oh, none of you are carrying a shotgun.
There is a shotgun deficiency here.
Get out of here.
All right.
They're all dead.
I guess I don't need shotguns.
I'm looping.
I'm circling.
I'm kiting.
The installation was specifically built to study and contain the fun.
Their survival as a race was dependent upon it.
I am grateful to see that some of them survived to reproduce.
Wait.
What are you grateful you fucking are?
Why?
They're killing me!
I'm so happy they're still alive.
Anyway, you might be dying right now, but not for the sake of humanity.
Bro!
None of them were spawning shotgunners!
He's not talking about the flood?
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
I was gonna be like, you asshole.
Oh my god!
That's the shotgunner!
Please!
Don't!
Don't do this to me!
He's literally right there!
Please!
Don't do this to me!
He's right there!
Oh my god!
I actually got a shotgun!
I lost most of my HP for this one gun!
It was not worth it.
It was not worth it, by the way.
It was absolutely not worth it.
I lost it all.
Nah, I have 5 bullets again.
Oh my god!
I got in my claw!
Thank god!
Oh, thank god!
There's a health pack.
I will deactivate the security lock.
Wait here.
Oh, please.
There's air vents and everything all around me.
Oh, my God.
There's no vet behind me, though.
There's no vet behind me, at least.
There's no vet behind me.
Oh, no.
Guys, they're flooding in.
They're actually flooding in.
Oh, my God.
Please.
Please, have mercy.
Have mercy on me.
Please.
I don't have enough HP for this.
Oh, my God.
No.
Oh, no.
Oh, please.
Oh, my God.
Please.
Please have mercy on me.
I don't deserve this.
I've been a good boy.
I've been such a good boy.
Holy shit.
I think the worst part is that when I'm reloading, it takes 20 years.
It takes so long to reload.
Okay.
Come on.
Jesus Christ.
I'm ready.
I still don't get...
I have to reload.
Oh, my God.
Oh.
There's no shotgun ammo.
I'll do this.
And just hope for the best.
And actually just hope for the best.
Right here.
Just hope for the best right now.
And I still don't grab...
I still don't grab any.
Guys, if I could grab another weapon, I would.
But none of the...
Everybody's dropping rifle right now.
Except for that one guy.
Except for him.
Oh, my God.
Thank God.
He's hand delivering me a shotgun.
He actually hand delivered me a shotgun for once.
Oh, my God.
Please.
Where is it?
Here it is.
I'm naining.
I'm naining everything.
Here we go.
There's so nothing.
Oh, no.
Please don't.
Get me.
Please.
Oh, my God.
The defense.
The defense team.
The defense team are here.
Thank God.
Oh, my God.
They're here.
And the shotgun.
A shotgun.
The Calvary is here!
Oh my god, the Calvary is no longer here.
The Calvary is no longer here.
Holy shit!
That was fast.
I did not expect the Calvary to die.
I did not die that fast, not gonna lie.
Okay, we still have some of them.
That was a bitch move.
We will call that a bitch move right there.
What's that?
Oh, there's another elevator.
Here's another one.
Ha ha ha!
Yay!
Halo is met in genre.
Shooter zombie survival rage game.
Prosecutor, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Ew.
Ha ha ha!
Oh!
Look up!
Oh my god!
This must be the last floor!
Okay.
Bye.
Gotta blow these guys up.
Real quick.
I see you.
Think I don't?
That's fucking right.
I see you.
I fucking see you!
You can't creep up on me like this!
I've played these games before!
Okay.
That's fine.
I wanna make sure my guy lives.
Okay.
I wanna make sure he has to live.
My little buddy!
You'll live for me!
Ow!
Don't worry!
I'll make sure he lives!
Oh my god.
They're just coming back to life.
Okay.
That was a waste of ammo.
Nevermind.
I think you mu- Nevermind.
You wasted so much of my ammo.
I don't- You don't need to live anymore.
Nevermind.
That might have been a waste.
Oh shit!
You brought a shotgun!
Nice!
I actually needed that!
That was all the ammo I lost!
Oh, I hear them.
Oh, I definitely hear them!
Oh!
It's fine.
We're okay.
We have a shotgun.
Whoa!
That's okay.
We needed that shotgun too.
It's okay.
They're just loot delivering to me.
Right?
Just a little loot delivery.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
Thank god.
Please reload.
Please.
Okay.
We're so healthy.
We're so, in fact, very healthy.
Oh.
Alright, we go this way.
The ammo is going down just like my sanity, guys.
As long as I blow up, one of them should be fine.
What?
Wait, what?
What do you mean?
Okay, I'll get rid of these guys first.
Oh god, there's way too many.
I'm in this corner!
This is a healthy corner!
Oh my god, this is still a healthy corner.
Oh my god!
Oh, why did I go in the corner?
Why did no one stop me?
Okay.
I don't know how to survive that.
I honestly don't know.
It was...
My depth was greatly exaggerated.
I have no idea.
What hit me?
What?
What happened?
Actually, what happened?
Bro, I don't even know what happened.
That's like the worst part.
I don't even know.
God!
What?
I don't know!
Okay, I'm just going to like...
go backwards.
I don't know what's killing me.
I actually don't know.
Oh my god, I didn't mean to fall down.
I didn't mean to fall down.
Okay.
Okay, it's just these guys.
Oh hey, I didn't even see you over here.
That's fine.
I knew you had shotgun.
There's nades?
Wait, I can like nade the nades and then die from the...
Oh my god, I didn't know you can die from like just...
That's a thing?
That's so stupid.
If I don't pick up the nades, I can die from nades.
Oh my god.
I didn't know that was a thing.
That's so dumb.
Okay, now I know.
At least now I know guys.
At least now I know.
Okay.
I don't know where my guy went.
Where did he go?
Where did my friend go?
Wait, did I go the wrong way?
Oh the metal!
Is that not a pit?
Oh the bee!
Alright, let's do this again.
Let's...
Let's try this again.
Guys, let's just...
I don't know where the bridge is.
I thought...
I thought that was a bridge.
Just run straight.
Okay.
Okay, now I know.
Guys, now I know.
And now I know.
And I think I'm dead.
I think I'm dead.
I think...
I don't have shotgun ammo.
Wait, I think that's a shotgun.
Shotgun.
I think he is holding a shotgun.
Wait, I think you're right.
Okay.
I'll make sure.
I'll go straight.
Oh my god, it's you again.
I just have to go straight.
I went the wrong way.
I knew I went the wrong way, too.
I fucking knew it.
I actually just went the wrong way.
Oh my god.
I went the way that I should never have...
The one way...
The one way I didn't have to go.
It was literally a 50-50.
Oh my god.
The other way I did it was the fucking other way.
I went up three times and then I went back down.
Like, how...
Now, retrieve the index.
I did it.
I...
Protocol requires that I take possession of the index.
What?
But I did it.
It renders you vulnerable to infection.
I...
I did it.
Before we reach the control room and activate the installation.
What?
The flood is spreading.
We must hurry.
Why did he take my...
Fancy stick?
I...
I did all the work.
Any organism with sufficient mass and cognitive capability is a potential factor.
Is...
Something wrong?
No.
Nothing.
Splendid.
Shall we?
No way I could get infected.
They made five more Halos after me.
Unfortunately...
My classification to...
Perform a task as important as the reunification of the index with the core.
That final step is reserved for you.
Yeah.
John Halo can't die.
That wasn't supposed to happen.
Huh?
Oh, really?
Ah.
Cortana.
I've spent the last 12 hours cooped up in here watching you toady about, helping that thing get set to slit our throats.
Hold on now.
Can you slit our...
Yeah.
He's friend-shaped.
I didn't realize.
He's your pal, is he?
Your chum?
Do you have any idea what that bastard almost made you do?
What?
Yes.
Activate Halo's defenses and destroy the flood.
Which is why...
Why is my wife mad at me?
You mean this?
A construct in the car?
That is absolutely unacceptable.
Sod off.
What impregnance.
I shall purge you at once.
You sure that's a good idea?
How?
How dare you?
Oh!
Do what?
I have the index.
You can just float and sputter.
Enough.
Stop fighting!
Stop!
I'm sorry, I was thinking of smiling friends when I saw that.
You have no idea how this ring works, do you?
Why the Forerunners built it?
Halo doesn't kill flood.
It kills their food.
Wait, that's us.
So it kills me.
Units, covenant, whatever.
We are all equally edible.
The only way to stop the flood is to starve them to death.
And that's exactly what Halo is designed to do.
Wipe the galaxy clean of all sentient lives.
That's Halo?
Wait, why the fuck do we let this happen, like, six more times?
Why?
What?
That's what Halo means?
Why the fuck do we still let it happen, try to happen five to six more times?
This galaxy will be quite devoid of life.
Or at least any life with sufficient biomass to sustain the flood.
But you already knew that.
I mean, how couldn't you?
Left out that little detail, did he?
We have filed outbreak containment procedure to the letter.
You were with me each step of the way as we managed this crisis.
Chief, I'm picking up movement.
Why would you hesitate to...
People never learn.
We need to go right now.
Last time you asked me, if it were my choice, would I do it?
Having had considerable time to ponder your query, My answer has not changed.
There is no choice.
We must activate the ring.
Get us out of here.
But why would a covenant want to kill every...
Like, all...
Like, their entire kind, too?
I suppose there be an action.
Give your construct to me, or I will be forced to take her from you.
That's not going to happen.
Soviet.
Save his head.
Dispose of the rest.
Huh?
No!
But we're friends!
Oh my god.
Please.
When did I get this gun?
Oh my god.
Oh, that's what betrayal is.
The gun pointed.
We can't let the monitor activate Halo.
We have to stop him.
Alright, guys.
We have to destroy Halo.
According to my analysis of the available data, I believe the best course of action is somewhat risky.
Alright, guys.
An explosion of sufficient size will help destabilize the ring, and will cut through a number of primary systems.
We need to trigger a detonation on a large scale, however.
A starship's fusion reactors going critical would do the job.
Wait, are we in a new chapter now?
...and see if I can locate the Pillar of Autumn's crash site.
If the ship's fusion reactors are still relatively intact, we can use them to destroy Halo.
Okay.
Did I do a checkpoint?
Am I at a checkpoint or no?
Because I don't want to do that fucking fight again.
I...
Was that...
Did I do a checkpoint when I killed those guys?
Yes, it's saved.
Alright, we're calling it here.
We're gonna...
I need to know...
I need to know when I killed all those sentinels, I need to know if there was a checkpoint.
Because I...
I don't...
I don't want to kill those sentinels again.
Uh...
Alright.
Wait, not yet?
Not...
Okay, we're...
Okay, wait, let me...
I'll make sure.
I need to make sure, guys.
Guys, okay.
I need to make sure...
I need to make sure that...
Alright.
Oh my god, you fuckers.
You fuckers actually almost...
Okay.
Now.
You guys almost made me do that again.
Okay.
Anyway, guys.
Like I said, we're just gonna do one...
One...
Um...
We were only gonna do one level.
After that, I think I went...
I went through a lot of trauma doing it.
Uh...
Doing the fucking library level.
And like I said, um...
It's a very long day for me tomorrow.
Um...
The two betrayals.
This was...
The first betrayal was from that...
The fucking orb.
The second betrayal was from the chat.
Like, that was where...
That's where the two betrayals came from.
Anyway, guys.
Um...
Like I said...
I was gonna do a short stream today.
I know it's like a lot shorter than my usual Halo streams.
Um...
But tomorrow and the day after tomorrow...
Are gonna be really busy for me.
Um...
And like tonight...
I actually have a lot of stuff to do in preparation for my concert tomorrow.
As well as my other two special...
Two streams...
Uh...
Tomorrow as well.
So...
Um...
I am going to call it here.
Uh...
Thank you everybody for watching.
I'm sorry I didn't know I started a stream late.
Uh...
But I still hope you guys had a great time watching.
Boom.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Did you enjoy the trauma?
I enjoyed it so much.
I actually unlocked a repressed memory from 10 years ago.
Like I...
You guys had actually...
I was like...
I never played Halo before.
But I forgot I did.
It was this level.
This one level that my friend made me try.
Like...
I repressed.
Um...
Anyway...
As always everybody...
Stay hydrated.
Poster checked.
Get up and move around.
To get that blood flowing.
And if you...
Except for me...
Head to bed.
Cause...
You deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.